this is a Fox News Alert just in moments
ago big changes could be coming in US
policy toward the World Health
Organization the widely discredited
World Health Organization good evening
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight
documents obtained by this show moments
ago suggest the Trump administration
will soon announce a major change in
America's posture toward w-h-o we'll
have details for you we're soaring
through them right now in just a moment
but first tonight the country appears to
be splitting into two hemispheres even
as we watch there are those places where
public officials are allowing science to
guide their decisions states like that
are cautiously beginning to relax their
lockdowns and finding no spike in
illness as they do it those are the free
states and then there's the other half
of the country the places we are glad
you don't live right now in those places
power-drunk politicians crow about
science but resolutely ignore its
findings they don't read the studies
they don't care what the data say their
decisions are driven by ambition
political calculation and the pure
animal joy of controlling other people's
lives places like that are tightening
their lock downs even now maybe no place
in the country represents the
authoritarian approach the Chinese
approach more starkly than Los Angeles
does LA County has more residents than
New York City
but while New York has had close to
200,000 confirmed cases of coronavirus
LA has had only about 35,000 in the
whole county now the real figure
certainly much higher than that
that's what we find every time
widespread testing takes place but
that's the point so few people in LA
have died relatively speaking that we're
not certain how many are infected we
know they're not sick enough to crowd
hospitals the city's health care system
has never come close to collapsing in
Los Angeles the curve is now flat and it
has been flat for weeks it could reopen
tomorrow and it should reopen and it
would if its leaders were following the
science but it's not reopening just the
opposite is happening Los Angeles Mayor
Eric Garcetti has now extended the
lockdown through the end of July that
means at least two and a half more
months of it he's using law enforcement
liberally to make certain that his
citizens obey his orders police say they
brought criminal charges
against at least 60 quote non-essential
businesses for the crime of going to
work tell us other businesses have shut
forever they're not coming back the
citizens who remain stuck in Los Angeles
are effectively hostages of the mayor
Garcetti has demanded that anyone who
goes outside for any reason as the heat
rises in LA must wear a mask it goes
without saying there is no science to
back up this order where any of Garcetti
s so-called
health decisions in fact it's possible
that requiring masks outside will not
prevent a single person from being
infected in Los Angeles but Carr said he
doesn't care anyone who disobeys this
order will be punished it's nots but
it's just the beginning of Eric Garcetti
'he's thoroughly bizarre restrictions
the more you know the weirder it is
watch for example as Garcetti explains
that anyone who goes to the beach must
make certain not to touch dry sand wet
sand is fine dry sand is now illegal
beaches will open up this week for
exercise and active recreation only in
the wet sand I guess is a good way of
thinking about it not hanging out and
tanning in the dry sand what's the
science behind this once again of course
there is none none this isn't reasoned
thoughtful policymaking it's the
expression of an autocrat who decided he
must look tough by doing something or he
won't get elected president which has
always been Eric Garcetti 'he's primary
goal it's scary if you think about what
this means it means that America's
second largest city has fallen under the
total control of a neurotic megalomaniac
who is terrified of dry sand Eric
Garcetti 'he's personal phobias are now
law in los angeles makes you think of
the final days of Nicolae Ceausescu and
romanian ranting in his subjects from
the podium imposing his strange
obsessions on a helpless population it
would not be surprising to learn that
Eric Garcetti is a compulsive hand
washer with a very strange personal life
guys like this are always the same once
you scratch the surface so how long will
los angeles have to live like this
possibly forever
Garcetti announced this week
we've never been fully closed we'll
never be completely open until we have a
cure but I do believe that we can take
steps but monitor those numbers listen
to the scientists and the medical
professionals and make the tough calls
even when there's criticism yeah this
can't go on it's too crazy
now you may mock Los Angeles in some
cases it's deserved there are some flaky
people who live there Barbra Streisand's
in Malibu but they're also an awful lot
of normal decent people in Los Angeles
millions of them and some of them
understand where Eric Garcetti is taking
them and their city and they've had
enough a couple of days ago a group of
them came together it's totally
bipartisan some of them are well-known
liberal Democrats some are conservative
Republicans and have been all their
lives there's a labor leaders middle
class voters the one thing they all have
in common is the dead certain knowledge
that Mayor Eric Garcetti is poison he's
hurting their city he's hurting their
families
Garcetti has allowed tens of thousands
of mentally ill drug addicts to live on
Los Angeles sidewalks and under
overpasses if you've been there recently
you know he's also tolerated flagrant
corruption in his own administration now
he shut the entire city down simply
because he feels like it this group of
citizens is going to try and bounce Eric
Garcetti from the mayor's office and
they can't under California law
politicians can be recalled by voters
you'll remember that Californians did it
to their governor Gray Davis seventeen
years ago it worked
now recall petition in California
requires three hundred and thirty
thousand signatures and that
unfortunately is where Eric Garcetti has
the advantage thanks to Garcetti
extended shelter-in-place orders
citizens are not allowed to gather these
signatures so under the guise of public
health
Garcetti has stopped his political
opponents from opposing him and he's not
the only one you've seen this happen in
many states Michigan New Jersey others
politicians around the country are doing
this as long as there is no vaccine for
the wuhan coronavirus they can remain in
power unchallenged forever it's nice for
them they're enjoying it but in Los
Angeles Garcetti may have gone too far
the future of the city is at stake
the recall Garcetti forces are taking
this issue the issue of signatures to
court trying to win the right to gather
the signatures online we'll keep you
posted on how they do because it's
important but the bigger point is these
people are not passive these are
Americans who understand what has been
taken from them and they are trying to
get it back as they should
we're seeing this happen around the
country thank God in New Jersey for
example citizens are still banned from
assembling to worship together as they
choose that's a direct violation of the
First Amendment's the US Constitution we
asked the governor of Jersey Phil Murphy
about this when he came on our show he
said he wasn't even really thinking
about the Bill of Rights when it comes
to controlling his population because
it's in the way